[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it is thus that enlightenment lets
itself be understood by faith it
presents itself in this bad life because
just by being in relation to another it
gives itself a negative reality or
exhibits itself as the opposite of
itself but pure insight and intention
must enter into this relationship for it
is their realization this at first
appeared as a negative reality perhaps
its positive reality is better
constituted let us see how things stand
with this if all prejudice and
superstition have been banished the
question arises what next what does the
truth enlightenment as propagated in
their stead it has already declared that
this positive content is in its
extirpation of error for that alienation
of itself is just as much it's positive
reality in its approach to what for
faith is absolute spirit it interprets
any determinate 'no such discoveries
there is wood stone etc as particular
real things since in this way it grasps
in general every determinant is all
content and filling as something finite
as a human entity and mere idea absolute
being becomes for it a vacuum to which
no determinations no predicates can be
attributed the attribution of predicates
to such a vacuum would be in itself
reprehensible and it is just in such a
union that the monstrosity is and
superstition have been produced reason
pure insight is certainly not empty
itself since the negative of itself is
for it and is its content on the
contrary it is rich but rich only in
particularity and limitations so let
nothing of that sort
a pertain to absolute being or be
attributed to it this is the prudent
behavior of reason or pure insight which
knows how to put itself and its finite
riches in their proper place and how to
deal with the absolute in a worthy
manner
there are two main things going on here
in paragraph 557 first Hegel is is
really giving us kind of a wrap-up of
what has happened in the previous
paragraphs that we have already
discussed and we'll come back to that in
a moment but what's really important
here where the forward movement is
taking place is in what he's talking
about as the positive reality of the
Enlightenment or indeed it's it's truth
its VAR height what it is that it shows
itself as being no longer there just in
terms of certainty but in a reflexive
way and you know this is particularly
important because the Enlightenment is
is portrayed both retrospectively by
Hegel looking back at it and by us
looking back at it from a much greater
distance where we almost mythologize
enlightenment oh hey we we turn it into
a much simpler period than it was but
also from its own you know movement
forward its own self understanding the
Enlightenment is being presented or it
presents itself as the the time in which
truth really starts to get its place so
we can't escape this issue of asking
well what is the truth of this this
enlightenment now this is indeed again
how we see Hegel prefiguring many of the
themes of what people these days like to
call deconstruction or the postmodern or
you know all those sorts of things he's
really making it talked about itself
which which is what tends to produce
some some issues the Enlightenment does
not actually measure up to its own
ideology and we're going to see that
happening much later in the absolute
freedom and the terror talking about
would happen in the French Revolution in
a very determinate way but we're already
seeing it here and Hegel in this
paragraph and then in the next paragraph
of the paragraph after that he's going
to talk about
three different aspects of that so here
he's sketching out the first aspect for
us let's go back to the wrap up material
though before we go into that so he says
it is less than enlightenment lets
itself be understood by faith so there
is a polemic going on not only of
enlightenment against a static faith
that that is stuck there sort of like a
boxer who can't throw any punches or
whenever he does throw punches he
telescopes them very widely and so they
they don't land and he blows instead you
know if you actually read some of the
works by people who we might see as
representing faith during the
Enlightenment they they provide some
serious counter-attacks you know some of
them are off-base but some of them are
things that enlightenment does have to
take seriously the same thing by the way
is going on in our own time in these
interminable debates between atheists
and theists right it's not as if the
atheists are the ones who always win in
terms of you know producing the best
arguments or unless you automatically
assume that the atheists are just going
to win they're the guys with the white
hats against the black hats in which
case you're a member of what Hegel's
calling this this this whole thing of
enlightenment right so the Enlightenment
has let itself be understood by faith as
not actually operating itself in good
faith you know bona fides you might say
and he says it presents itself in this
bad light now notice he says it presents
itself faith allowed enlightenment to
speak for itself it didn't just come up
with some cookie cutter schematic things
and then shoved enlightenment into that
the way that we see so many theistic
polemics against faith - in our own time
the better ones actually say oh so wait
what is it that you actually believe
what is it that you're teaching about
what we religious people say oh that's
very interesting let's look at that a
little bit more carefully oh can I get
some clarification
from you on just how priestcraft and
superstition have have messed things up
through history and then it comes in and
says well here's where you got this
drawing this drawing this wrong what do
you have to say for yourself and what
it's doing is taking enlightenment as we
saw in the previous paragraph add its
own word and this presents problems at
first so he says enlightenment gives
itself a negative reality or exhibits
itself as the opposite of itself right
it's supposed to be eminently practical
turns out not to be quite so practical
faith ends up being more practical turns
out you know we can go on and on and on
in these critiques I don't need to
rehearse them because we already covered
that
so he says pure insight and intention
must enter into this relationship for it
is their realization you see
enlightenment enlightenment is sort of
like a curiosity and an integrity that
must drive itself forward that cannot
escape by making excuses by cutting
corners because if it does it's just as
much of a lying game as all that stuff
that was going on in culture or that it
thinks is going on in faith Hegel's used
this dynamic a number of times in the
past you know when we have genuine
ethical commitment that means being
willing to sacrifice one's own creature
comforts one's own social status one's
own
wanting to be right about things to see
where reason or self-consciousness or if
you like spirit does in fact lead us so
this this puts enlightenment and pure
insight into a bit of a dilemma doesn't
it and different people are gonna go
different ways some are going to become
in essence fundamentalists or apologists
of the Enlightenment others are going to
take the Enlightenment yet further and
continue on it's Dinah
or what Hegel calls the dialectic so he
says this diff first appeared as a
negative reality now we get into the
second part perhaps in its positive
reality it's better constituted so now
let's take a look at what he's calling
this positive reality here's the
question if all prejudice and
superstition have been banished this
question arises what next what is the
truth enlightenment has propagated in
their stat what is the truth of the
enlightenment what is it
offering in place of superstition in
place of prejudice in place of a focus
on you know picture thinking and
particularity what does it have to offer
us after we've pulled down the statues
and closed up the churches and told all
the peasant people to quit you know
worshipping at these shrines and given
them some books instead and brought them
into school and educated them and taught
them some natural science this is a
fundamental question now notice this is
a question that we can ask sort of
prospectively even before the
enlightenment is finished and you know
usually it sounds a lot better the
answers that are given at that time by
comparison to what we actually see when
you run into them so Hegel is going to
say here enlightenment has already
declared this positive content is in its
extirpation as that's rooting out
tearing tearing out the error for that
alienation of itself is just as much
it's positive reality so this is very
important we've talked about this a
number of times
pure insight has a certain kind of
circularity or reflexivity to it but it
also has a kind of emptiness it doesn't
have the content that that faith has the
in halt in in German what is its content
its content is a negative one that of
negating or critiquing faith so can and
why
and continue to exist after faith has
been taken off the scene after it has
been abolished will enlightenment remain
enlightenment or is it going to become
you could say self critiquing self
eating is it going to prey upon itself
so he goes on and he says in its
approach to what for faith is absolute
spirit enlightenment proposes a
different way of understanding it how is
enlightenment going to be worshiping or
at least conceiving of God absolute
being the divine could be the universe
if you like there's a lot of different
variations possible or humanity you know
we could we take Fourier Bach and other
humanists and ask what are they going to
put in place of the object of faith and
Hegel says there's an important
distinction that's being made here
that's going to render this into a kind
of void or in German here vacuum all
right vacuum that's just the Latin term
and there were many debates about this
are are there really voids while Hegel
is saying we can at least imagine a void
and that is what enlightenment which is
supposed to be all about reason is doing
its imagining a subject without any
predicates whatsoever so he goes on and
he says it interprets any determinate
Ness in absolute spirit as wood or stone
or things like that you know a statue
sort of rosary beads whatever it is that
you like as determinacy and therefore as
a kind of limitation this is why it
thinks faith is really about
superstition superstition would take the
wood the stone as being the reality of
the absolute being and so he says here
we go it interprets these as particular
real things and since in this way it
grasps and Jenna
every determinate necessity as idea as
essentially projection on our part
projection by the person of faith
perhaps without knowing so in which case
they are just superstitious and foolish
or perhaps knowingly in which case they
are a hypocrite
Hegel saying that the Enlightenment
perspective takes that as you might say
below the dignity of the absolute and
below the dignity of the human being so
it proposes something different instead
a more direct relationship he says
absolute being becomes rid of vacuum to
which no determinations no predicates
can be attributed the attribution of
predicates to such a vacuum would be
reprehensible
there is a normative claim being staked
out here by the Enlightenment you can't
talk about God as caring about one
particular people on earth or as
commanding that these people
historically do this thing this
institution that that would be unworthy
of a genuine deity who cares for the
entire universe you can't say that God
would manifest himself itself herself or
whatever you want to call it in this
determinate content here that say this
religious text this temple this ritual
that would be unworthy of the divine so
he goes on and he says it's just from
such a union that monstrosity is a
superstition have been produced this you
know the human mind couldn't be content
with grasping the purity of God who we
can find you know the Enlightenment
thought that we could find God through
pure reason the joke on them turned out
of course to be that no once you start
doing that you find out that somebody
else can equally argue from pure reason
so there not being a god or not
the kind of God that you're talking
about and really you can't even defend
your concept of God because you've
already removed all the predicates from
it so there's not a lot to work with but
we're not we're not quite there yet so
for pure insight is opposing this idea
to the idolatry of faith he's saying so
he goes on and he says reason is
certainly not empty itself reason is not
this this thing over here reason is got
some sort of content precisely by being
negation albino for it it can
conceptualize itself as negative and it
also conceptualizes its opposite which
is faith so he says on the contrary it
is rich the the reason of the individual
person right it is rich but only rich in
particularity and limitations the
individual person understanding himself
herself as the person of enlightenment
in this entire dynamic understands
themselves by contrast to the absolute
being as a determinant being as
particular as limited I am male not
female
you know I am now middle-aged not young
Hey
I am this tall I am not short I'm not
super tall we go on and on and on with
these sorts of predicates so he says to
let nothing of that sort
a pertain to absolute being that is the
prudent behavior of reason of pure
insight which knows how to put itself
and its finite riches its resources in
their proper place and how to deal with
the absolute in a worthy manner what
we're talking about here is an
Enlightenment critique of religion in
favor of a purified religion a better
relationship to the absolute being
in contrast to this empty being there
stands is the second moment of the
positive truth of enlightenment the
singleness in general of consciousness
and of all being a singleness excluded
from absolute being and in the form of
absolute being in and for itself
consciousness which in its first reality
has sent certainty and mere meaning
returns here to this from the whole
course of its experience and is again a
knowledge of what is purely negative of
itself or of things of sense that is of
things which immediately and indifferent
ly confront its being for self here
however it is not an immediate natural
consciousness on the contrary it has
become such for itself whereas at first
it was at the mercy of every sort of
entanglement into which it was plunged
by its unfolding and now has been led
back by pure insight into its first
shape it has experienced that shape as a
result being based on the nothingness of
all the other shapes of consciousness
and hence of everything beyond sense
certainty this sense certainty is no
longer mere meaning but rather absolute
truth there's nothing miss of everything
that lies beyond sense certainty is no
doubt merely a negative proof of this
truth but it is not susceptible of any
other for the positive truth of sense
certainty is in its own self the
immediate being for self of the notion
itself qua object and that too in the
form of other napoo that every
consciousness is absolutely certain that
it is and that there are other real
things outside of it and that in its
natural being it like those things is in
and for itself or absolute
in the previous paragraph Hegel talked
about the first aspect of the truth of
enlightenment what it was that that
enlightenment had actually brought
forward as the truth that would replace
superstition priestcraft faith what's
the second that's what he's going to
discuss here in paragraph 558 and he
says that in contrast to this empty
absolute being wich which he will talk
about which is still there in the
background now he's going to sketch out
what is happening in terms of the
subject the the individual person who is
enlightened who is engaging in
enlightenment as an activity and he says
what we're talking about here is the
singleness the enzone the height of
consciousness and of all being all being
except for of course the absolute being
this is quite interesting though because
he's going to almost immediately talk
about absolute being in and for itself
consciousness but now we're talking
about the single the individual
consciousness even we might say the
separated consciousness the one that is
separating itself off from the rest of
the world in its own understanding and
the other thing that's really
interesting about this passage is that
you notice he has here brought back in
sense certainty but he says that we've
returned to this stage of sense
certainty which was the very beginning
of the dialectic but we've returned in a
different way we've gone through all of
these sub lations all of these out hable
all right and consciousness now is
trying to grasp the world as a world of
sensuous objects but it's not
approaching them with the same sort of
naivete that it did at first so he says
we have a
singleness excluded from absolute being
and in the form of absolute being in and
for itself consciousness which in its
first reality in the very beginning of
this book right was sense certainty as
he says and mere meaning mining there's
kind of play on words there of course
because you know mine and means to
intend or or to you know to mean but it
also means sort of the act of
appropriation you know making it mine
alright or expressing what is mine and
he says it returns here from the whole
course of its experience which is this
entire work right consciousness has been
building itself up and it's now
something different having gone through
these earlier stages of development
because it's again a knowledge of what
is purely negative of itself
things are sense why are things of sense
purely negative of itself
well consciousness itself is that
something that is of sense I don't know
can you smell your consciousness can you
hear your consciousness can you turn
your eyeballs around and look inside and
see your consciousness now of course you
might say well you know we put you in
the MRI machine and neuroscience shows
you your consciousness we've already
been through that in the physiognomies
and phrenology part what neuroscience
actually shows us is MRI scans or
correlations or interesting pictures but
doesn't show us consciousness itself we
are however conscious we exercise our
consciousness practically as well as
theoretical E and we do so encounter
distinction to the things of sense that
arise for us and we can say well I am
still a thing of sense I am one object
among the world but I'm a peculiar kind
of object this almost sounds if those
those of you have read jean-paul Sartre
is starting to sound a little bit like
the Being and Nothingness arrangement
the in itself or the for itself well
Sartre took those concepts from from
Hegel in part so he says here however it
is not an immediate natural
consciousness on the contrary it has
become so so there's been a process of
estrangement or alienation and a process
of reconciliation or recuperation
reintegration you might say so he says
whereas at first meaning back in the
sense certainty section and earlier
sections he was at the mercy of every
sort of entanglement into which it was
plunged by its own unfolding it had no
idea what it was unfolding into by the
way and now has been led back by a pure
insight right - it's per shape it has
experienced that shape as a result it's
no longer just a thing that it's thrown
into this is something it can look
backwards at and say AHA you know what
is one of the things that you could
might see in the Enlightenment I guess
the Epicureans were right maybe it
really is just bodies and the ways that
they're arranged and this is what does
happen with some figures who are
thinking about things or you know maybe
those other materialists were right
maybe the people who had a sort of naive
reaction to the sense world and said
yeah I don't know about that spirit or
psyche or whatever it is that you're
calling it
Plato Aristotle you know whoever
Christians Jews maybe they were right
that's what the Enlightenment person is
actually asserting so he goes on and he
says being based on the nothingness of
all the other shapes of consciousness
and hence everything beyond sense
certainty this sense certainty is no
longer mere meaning but rather absolute
truth so what we have here is a stage of
the Enlightenment where the
Enlightenment
is looking back and saying they had it
right at Sun certainty they just didn't
realize that they had it right each of
these other stages each of these
projects where we thought that we had
realized what consciousness really is
what what the absolute being is and
turned out not to fulfill its promises
but to open a way to yet another state
or shape or dynamic for consciousness
and now we're here now we can actually
say okay we're going back to that that
stance but we're doing so in a
thoughtful way so he goes on and he says
the nothingness of everything that lies
beyond sense certainty is no doubt a
merely negative proof of this truth but
it's not susceptible he says of any
other the nothingness of absolute being
itself the nothingness of the rest of
the world this is this is Hegel
depicting something similar to what
Heidegger later on we'll call finitude
isn't it so he goes on and he says the
positive truth of self certainty is it's
in its own self the immediate being for
self of the notion itself qua object how
it's relating itself to itself and that
too in the form of other nests the
things that we sense are other than us
but we are sensing them we're the ones
who grasp them the world circulates you
might say around our vantage point even
though in another sense we can say well
I know the world doesn't circulate
around our vantage point and the
universe isn't centered around this
piddly little planet in this tiny solar
system but consciousness is special in a
sense so he goes down and he says the
positive truth that every consciousness
is absolutely certain that it is and
that there are other real things outside
it and that in its natural being it like
those things is and and for itself and
absolute this is the second aspect of
what Hegel is calling the truth of the
Enlightenment this is the way the
enlightenment is you might say
constructing its metaphysics making
sense out of itself and it's doing so in
such a way that the people can say aha
through this framework I can understand
what the hell I am and what objects are
and what the relationship between us is
we don't need to necessarily bring in
the absolute being in order to do so
although that is going to come back yet
you